President Trump has escalated the US
trade tensions with China he's
threatening to raise tariffs again on
essentially all remaining imports from
China which are valued at an estimated
300 billion dollars this comes after the
Chinese delegation left meetings with US
officials in Washington yesterday with
No Deal Nikole Killion is at the White
House Nicole good morning good morning
to you Michelle president Trump said the
talks were candid and constructive and
insisted that his relationship with
China's president is strong even as he
moves to raise tariffs on Chinese goods
which could potentially impact millions
of Americans trade talks between the US
and China lasted just two hours Friday
and ended without a deal the nearly one
year trade spat reignited an all-out
trade war overnight the US Trade
Representative said the president
ordered us to begin the process of
raising tariffs on essentially all
remaining imports from China which are
valued at 300 billion dollars this comes
after president Trump slapped a 25
percent tariff on 250 billion dollars
worth of Chinese goods Friday the
president tweeted talks continue but
noted that tariffs may or may not be
removed depending on what happens with
respect to future negotiations later he
told POLITICO his tweet seems to be
having quite an impact on the market I
looked the market was down he said now I
think it's up so it shows you what
happens you know with the piggy banks
that everybody wants to rob earlier in
the week President Trump took aim at
China saying the US has been taken
advantage of
they allowed China to freely loot our
economy but before that he expressed
optimism about reaching a deal let's
work together let's see if we can get
something done in a barrage of retweets
the president said tariffs will bring in
far more wealth to our country than even
a phenomenal deal of the traditional
kind so they'll be paying we don't make
the deal however US importers and
companies are likely to bear the cost of
the tariffs when goods arrived from
China that would mean higher prices for
American
consumers which could then eventually
weaken the Chinese economy since they're
good to become more expensive you're
gonna see both American companies and
Chinese companies probably being you
know hurt equally by the tariffs so
there's going to be symmetric pain being
felt I think on both sides of the
Pacific Ocean
China is vowing to retaliate with
necessary countermeasures which would
likely include higher tariffs on US
products Chinese officials hope to
continue trade talks with the u.s. in
Beijing although Anthony we still don't
know when that could happen Nicole
thanks